what I said in the inquiry about not
wanting to change anything was based on
the actions of my firefighters on the
nights clearly knowing what we know now
about the building and about ACM
cladding we would do things differently
but the one thing I want to make clear
is if I caused any additional hurt or
upsets the people of Grenville that was
never my intention the loss of life
suffered those 72 people who lost their
lives the families the bereaved people
we will never ever forget them and we
never want anything like this to happen
again did you regret those comments that
you made back I mean would you do the
same again I regret they caused offense
what I was trying to make clear was that
the actions of my firefighters on the
night when an unprecedented set of
circumstances they were challenging they
were you know difficult there was
something we'd never faced and what I
didn't want some people's think my
firefighters hadn't done their very best
on the night but it was never intended
to cause offence well let's come now to
the state courts policy the inquiry says
had that been revoked nearly an hour
earlier that would very likely have been
fewer fatalities do you agree with that
I think it's very difficult to reach
that conclusion without understanding
fully how the building performed on that
night which is why we welcomed in phase
2 not only as they're going to be smoke
modeling but evacuation modeling because
I think even the chairman of the inquiry
himself has said he's reached that
conclusion without any expert evidence
it's a conclusion he's reached I think
it's very difficult to make that
assertion without the full understanding
of what happened slavish adherence to it
I'm thinking it's like a religion your
officers your commands you couldn't
think on your feet the building's going
up very very quickly this is the picture
painted by the report but you still
stick by that state policy so stay put
is not a London Fire Brigade policy it's
a policy built on buildings and the fact
the fire should stay contained you still
think it's the right thing to do so we
know over the last five years we've had
over 5,000 high-rise fires in London for
which absolutely virtually all of them
stay put has been the right policy and
has protected the people in those
buildings so you're saying it was the
right thing to do
obviously for Grenfell town not to
Grenville tower know clearly now knowing
what we know about the building knowing
not only about the highly flammable
cladding but all the fire safety
breaches no of course not we do
different things and we've learnt and
we've got different steps in place now
you say now knowing what we know about
the cladding but there is an issue there
isn't you did know about the cladding
you did know that cladding was highly
combustible you did know that it could
have had that effect because you'd seen
it happen before you'd seen it happen in
the lack in our house fire in 2009
so obviously the report saw it obviously
lack of a house fire we've identified
we're lacking our house reckoned ation
recommendations were made that the under
fire brigade did not fully adhere to
learn and we've put steps in place the
cladding there was different it was a
window unit we've never seen a building
if a fallen was the same you should have
known so nobody has ever seen a building
form in the way grenfell did because it
wasn't just about the cladding it was
about the breaches internal in
compartment ation no building has ever
behaved like that no building ever
should but your firefighters on the
grounds should have been aware that that
could have happened had they been aware
because they'd been given the correct
training which has been described as
gravely inadequate we might not be
talking about 72 people dead
that's the point so the point for me is
that on the night the fire behaved as an
exceptional way as Sir Martin more bits
identified my firefighters displayed
incredible courage commitment and
bravery I'm really pleased that's been
recognized it was in circumstances of a
building with a staircase there was a
meter wide we're talking about
firefighters going into that building
trying to get people out down a very
narrow smokey staircase I think it's
very difficult to say had the building
been evacuated earlier what the
circumstances would have been I really
welcome phase 2 looking at all those
factors and circumstances but the main
thing for me is understanding that a cm
cladding that is flammable is not fit to
be on buildings and we've still got
buildings in London they've got it on
it wasn't fit to be on building so I
mean the accusation ultimately is that
you as the leader of this organization
were criminally negligent so I think
that you know we it's right that the
police are the ones who look into that
we're fully cooperating with the police
we've supplied them with interviews and
we've obviously been interviewed under
caution and that's right and proper
they've said they can't reach any
conclusion till after phase 2 because
there are so many circumstances that
have not been fully identified and
explored yet one of the things that was
said to me by some of the survivors
yesterday is that they can't really
understand why you are retiring it's
been reported that you have a pension
pod of two million pounds why you are
retiring why haven't you resigned so
you're in a public office why haven't
you resigned
what can understand that the people of
Grenfell are hurting and the people of
grenfell want somebody to be accountable
I absolutely understand that what's been
important for me and continues to be
important for me is that we are putting
steps in place to change things we are
learning we've identified our own areas
that we've been concerned about way
before the inquiry it's important for me
that I continue to protect the people of
London by putting those steps in place
and developing London Fire Brigades and
by resigning now that would not happen
but do you think people trust you I
don't think people think about in terms
of trust I think people I think it's
London Fire Brigade that they trust
because London Fire Brigade are there
protecting the people of London day in
and day out trusting so I think for me
the important thing is recognizing that
I am here now I'm committed to learning
I'm not running away from any of this
I'm standing here and I'm taking
responsibility for London Fire Brigade